well as always thank you all for being
here I'm it's uh 10 past 10 I'm going to
convene our meeting
and as is our custom we'll begin with
the Pledge of Allegiance
of the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God individual liberty and
justice for all
well thank you colleagues for being here
as I've mentioned before the meeting we
don't have a quorum but that
doesn't have to stop us from having a
discussion we're simply not going to be
taking any votes unless we have a quorum
so uh
representative lean you you mentioned
there were a couple of things you'd like
to discuss we can begin with that
foreign
s
um
there were some things that we had
decided to put off
um
and one of those was we call it the LLC
I know you don't like the word loophole
but it's the LLC basically that's
dropped out out of courtesy I will not
take exception to that
[Music]
used in the past by both parties
actually
to get around the individual
contribution limits so and my concern is
that we limit what corporations can give
and we but we don't allow Partnerships
or llc's
they can give everything so my question
was do we need to bring them into the
fold and at least address that they have
to be
there are limits that apply to them and
that they have to somehow have to
register and say what they're spending
in the interest of transparency
there's two questions I guess in there
one do we limit them three do we include
them do we limit them
and then do we make them report
so those are three and it's to address
all kinds of organizations and why are
we just singling out corporations
would you re would you repeat those
three again please
um include them
include to include llc's
I think we've uh the Partnerships are
excluded
they can't give money at all
um unions can't give money
I think it's limited Partnerships so
basically I think in the in here in the
in the 664 it talks about organizations
but it doesn't really Define
organizations
and in most
parts
of the law organizations includes
all kinds of entities so it would be
corporations limited partners anything
that can be quote a person underneath
the law so for instance if you look at
corporate law
and that's part of what citizens united
was about was corporations are persons
so if a corporation is a person why is
there any reason not to include these
other entities at least so that we know
what they're doing and if we want limits
on them to put them in
and we haven't really talked about that
because we've been focusing on other
things and we had agreed to kind of wait
till the end
so I think I've articulated it you know
my concern is
consistency and to be sure that
um that if there are known ways that
people are getting around the limits
that we at least deter them in some way
or make it I think somebody said it once
make it at least a little more difficult
for them to do that and that it's in
plain sight so that people can see it
and see what's happening
okay
okay hang on
if and if you look at business
organization is to find it's on the top
of 223
of the book I don't know
um it it's
664 right two in the definitions Roman
numeral xbi right to mean any
Corporation partnership limited
liability company proprietorship so we
have business organizations
defined here but we don't have the word
just organization I don't think defined
uh it is it is defined in here but I'm
going to find it okay good but but it's
not a definition I think is very useful
when I find it I'll read it to you and
tell you why I think that
uh
because one of the reasons I think when
we had our initial discussions we talked
about defining person as a human being
and then we talked about having
organization mean everything else but
that was way at the beginning when we
first started down this road so
I've got to find it okay it basically uh
for the purposes of one of these
sections or paragraphs or Clauses
whatever you want to call it it defines
an organization as one or more people
this is kind of it's kind of a separate
issue but I I just kind of see an
organization consisting of one person
that
well an LLC is an organization that can
have single member and frankly that's a
lot of small businesses in New Hampshire
but yeah it it's Crea it's a personal
it's an entity with one member and it's
being done to protect them from
liability
right and it's defined and it's included
under business organization
so that that was one minor let me find
it okay
I'm just gonna
all right and it always seems longer
when you think people are waiting too
[Laughter]
uh here we are I found it
uh
in uh
664 colon 2 Roman numeral three
political committee means right it's a
paragraph after
uh part e
just above the Roman numeral four as
used in this paragraph
organization includes but is not limited
to
one or more natural persons
entities formed under the law
what a more natural one or more natural
persons
semicolon entities formed under state
law
except those entities qualified under
Section 501c3
uh committees formed by a candidate
exploratory campaign or political party
so so I stand corrected it is
well it does include the LLC elsewhere
explicitly under business organization
and it also says entities
formed under state law which I think
would also include an LLC that has no
existence except under state law so then
we have so this is kind of an aside from
your main point but
it just seems to me that
where it says one or more natural
persons it would make more sense to me
to say two or more natural persons
well there are entities
except how can you put your microphone
on please I think in the in the marked
up draft from the Secretary of State
they did change it to two oh okay I
haven't well
is that
includes
well that one of that is because we
we were talking about the term includes
sometimes it said let Aaron speak to
this when she gets here but I guess part
of me is entities formed under the state
law there are corporations that have
single numbers and there are llc's that
have single members so
then are we limiting the corporations to
only those that have more than one
shareholder
I don't think so because and and then an
entity
an entity formed under state law would
include an LLC which was the focus of
your concern in this discussion
and it also included explicitly
elsewhere under business organization
right what what my change would do would
mean that we're not confusing an
activity by a single individual natural
person
with an organization
correct but I I think this definition
doesn't do that but maybe I'm misreading
it
because we we were talking about because
what's strict what would it what was was
is it the but not limited to that was
struck it says includes changes
if if you read it without that uh
parenthesis
Clause set off by commas but is not
limited to includes one or more natural
persons
to me that it's not part of the
what almost anybody my opinion of course
right I think I think we can ask about
because
political committee is two people
correct they get together
so that wouldn't be right any
organization of two or more persons but
a single individual by by my definition
can't be an organization right and
that's fine and then we've got then
semicolon and
right it would be any entity that's a
separate item in the list
I'm sorry I don't mean to be
interrupting your
so
I guess I'll look at what
two or more natural persons
yeah
and there that defines organization not
business organ it's the same way yeah
and we had talked about they're
different definitions yeah
and I see that representative Ward is
correct of course that the draft that we
just received from
deputy secretary Hennessey
also would suggest the same change
but
I didn't mean to digress from your main
focused there but that was right so I I
guess I'm still trying to I guess one
question we can ask is do we need the
term business organization as well as
this and maybe we do maybe we don't and
then
um oh
why are
why are we including some entities but
it looks like these were including
entities but we're are we still
excluding
is there a way for conflict because we
have another provision over here that
talks about people that can't give right
and then we exclude those
and you mentioned unions yes uh
and that goes back to 1999 that case in
19 minutes and I
strongly suspect from past discussions
we've had on this committee that
allowing unions as an entity to
contribute is something that would
require a great deal of discussion and
debate if we were ever to it was ever to
be agreed we have to defer that one
until the next I think that's one we
would
practically speaking would defer yeah
yeah is that as I've mentioned I think
we all agree with this we're looking for
the areas we can you know I'll agree on
right
and I'm sure there are such uh topics
and I I can think of arguments against
allowing unions as an entity to
contribute but I'm not going to go into
them we'll save that for the day we have
that discussion again
is when we put in
limits
is it is the limit approach applicable
only to corporations or is it applicable
to business organizations
so right now we have an existing piece
of the statute
and I think it's Roman numeral number
four
or whatever but puts a limit on what
individuals and corporations can give
but it corporations is the only business
entity that is limited in that regard as
to amount
so
my question is why do we do that just
with that one entity and I guess if the
statute is silent then does that mean
the other entities can give unlimited
amounts because they're not listed
anywhere that I know of I'm happy to be
corrected
uh we will be asking for your input at
some point
uh deputy secretary Hennessey
uh let's see
and I think it's on
it's in that
um
Instagram
I should know it by heart at this size
664 4.
so on page 226 and it's been amended
already again since this one but Roman
numeral four has not been amended and
right and that states uh right
by a person
that that's that's the uh this is 664
colon 4 Roman numeral four and it's what
sets the contribution limits right by a
personal Corporation right so and then
silence on other types of
business organizations I think and then
five is the one that the next thing I
want to talk about but that was changed
by the senate in our budget but let's
put that off for now but so so my
question is in Roman numeral four do we
want to say by a person or business
organization an access of the following
amounts in other words why are we do why
are we differentiating between a
corporation and these other entities
because right now I think they're
Unlimited
yeah I don't know the answer to that
nor do you right
I I don't I think the reasoning goes
back to the case in 1999 and there and
limited liability companies were not as
big a thing in 1999 as they are now I
mean historically I think I think in I
think the first time they were enacted
and I'm doing this totally from memory
so it's probably gonna be wrong but I
think it was around 1995.
and they kind of came into bow
over those following 10 years
and as a as a preferred method of
setting up a business entity because it
allowed I'm going to get really into the
weeds here it allows pass-through
taxation you're not taxed twice and so
the corporation doesn't pay taxes and
then the individuals so it eliminates
that double taxation so a lot of
business people like to use them
makes sense because it's a pass-through
entity so they're not paying as much
taxes
so
it kind of came into so I think that's
one reason why it's kind of not been in
here is when it originally this was
originally changed was in 1999 I don't
think anybody's ever really looked at it
and then when we started talking about
some of the
LLCs that were being formed and how they
were contributing millions of dollars to
some campaigns both Democrat and
Republican
um how do we put at least disclose that
and how and if we want to put a limit on
the way we're limiting corporations why
don't we limit them as well
so again that's a two-prong question
do we include them and if we do do we
limit them
and you know maybe we do need to talk
about that in the next
cycle but I to me it's it doesn't make
sense and it's part of the history but
it's not been brought up I think by
either the Secretary of State or the AG
because it's not really something and
Aaron can correct me if I'm wrong I
don't think it's something that comes up
to them but to me it's from a
transparency standpoint and where we
want to do do we want to have them be as
transparent as the corporations I mean
why should they not have to be as
transparent as the other business
entities
okay
that's all
um
and I think and I know that one concern
we had was does the does the benefit of
transparency outweigh the cost of the
people complying and I think with
many llc's I because of the amount of
money that is being contributed
it's significant so I think in my
opinion to benefit outweighs the costs
and if an entity if an LL small LLC
wants to give money then they can give
money but then they just have to whoever
they give it to has to disclose it and
then they have to disclose it
as well
whoever they're giving the money to has
to disclose it
right yeah
but should there be a limit to that I
don't know
my thought is if we're limiting
corporations why aren't we limiting
other entities as well
I'm not a lawyer I'm not a lawyer and
it's probably but but when I
when I read
664 colon for Roman numeral four
by a person or Corporation
see I as a as a layperson in the legal
field
I would interpret Corporation as
including an LLC
it wouldn't no okay that's more your no
it wouldn't which is why it's listed
separately you know in other places and
I I mean that we can ask the AG but I
don't think that they would
okay I don't think from a legal
standpoint because there's a whole
group of statutes that deal with
corporations and then there's a whole
group of statutes that deal with LLC so
they're treated very differently
in the law
so I think if we were going to have to I
think they should be distinguished
okay I understand your opinion
and I would
need to have more information and more
have given a lot more thought before I
was ready to
agree if ever to such a change
I I one bit of information that would be
helpful to have and considering this is
to know
how much
how often this occurs
with llc's
and as as we've discussed between us in
the past I'm not
uh
I'm not convinced that contribution
limits in principle are necessarily
uh
acceptable or effective
in the interest of transparency if
candidates are required to disclose
receipts which they are passed Beyond a
total of a thousand right
if you received
no a candidate as a candidate is
required to register and make reports if
expenditures exceed one thousand
political committees including candidate
committees I believe are required to
register and Report when it's
receipts or expenditures
right
so I think in the interest of
transparency having the candidate
reporting
this information
is the key for transparency
but that's again that's
subject of discussion right so I I
understand you're concern about
contribution limits as as we've
discussed in the past between us
I'm not as concerned about that as
about the establishing limits
the contribution limits you mean you're
not as just I'm not as concerned as some
people that there be contributions
I
do agree that transparency requires that
Beyond some threshold we understand
where candidates
campaign financing is coming from
so as the Secretary of State stated in
are meeting with them in this room
so we the voters can judge if they think
there's undo the possibility of undue
influence going on that that I agree
with but
uh
in any case even candidates when their
expenditures exceed a thousand dollars
they are responsible to report receipts
and expenditures
as I understand it back to the elect
back to the beginning of that election
cycle yeah and I think so yeah and I
think part of part of the problems on
the transparency piece is that
the names of these organizations
don't really disclose who is giving the
money so you say ABC you know ABC LLC
it doesn't say who is behind a ABC
all you know is that name and when you
go and look them up in the Secretary of
State's office there are no names that
just gives so there are no names that
just gives the names of some some of the
key members perhaps but not
but not names not individual names so
it's it's transparent in the sense that
you are learning
you are learning the names of who's
giving but the name itself doesn't
really get you anywhere because
it's not telling you much
so I think that's one and the same is
true corporations but we won't put that
aside for now
because at least you have the some of
the things are listed in a lot of the
corporations you can get to but LLCs are
a little trickier
it's it's more apparent transparency
than real transparency correct
from my perspective that's a discussion
we would need to defer to another okay
well I'll hold you to it not I don't
think it's something we're going to be
able to to agree on here to agree on in
within this subcommittee okay so and I
I'm still convinced there's plenty we
will be able to agree on that we'll be
in them will be improvements to the
current
status we'll refer that to the next
subcommittee
or the next legislator who wishes to
file okay
okay yeah
okay legislative service request right
yeah
okay and then I guess the
what happened in the budget
and
um when the Senate put in hb2 the
provision that packs and it's in Roman
numeral five of that same bill 664 for
the same statute rather
that now packs are limit Unlimited
so when we read it
in our book right now it says a total of
thirty thousand and right now it's been
changed to to Unlimited
and
I'm just bringing it up because it was
never just brought before us we never
had any public
hearing on it it just got added on to
the
Bill and do we want to at least talk
about it maybe not maybe the
subcommittee is not the right place but
I just wanted to at least have a
conversation about it because it's
something that's happened since we
started looking at these things
uh yeah I was looking at that also uh
it's all right it was a Roman numeral
five and 664 call
colon 4.
it previously read that uh prohibited
contribution by any candidate committee
non-candidate political committee or
political advocacy organization in
excess of the following amounts and
contributed to a candidate or candidate
committee was limited to
10 000 during each of the phases of a
typical election cycle
uh
but here the what they called here
exploratory phase and right primary and
general election now it's Unlimited in
each phase
and the previous total limit per
election cycle of 30 000 is now
Unlimited
I had a thought related to this but not
not really going along the lines you're
interested in I just wanted
another another topic we should discuss
at some point maybe maybe we'll uh draw
up drafts of our ideas
uh but
a topic that I think is related to this
because of the listing of different
types of political
organizations we're talking about
simplifying
the number of different political
and the different political committees
as near as I can tell are just as we're
calling them different types they're
distinguished by
uh reporting thresholds primarily
uh
and
just the thought I had for example I
don't see a difference a real meaningful
difference between a political
advocacy organ generally a political
committee
I mean there's a threshold there's a
threshold at which they have to start
reporting but
why are they distinguished
yeah I
I could be incorrect but are ended in
like uh 501 C4s there are entities that
are
um
that do do they're not 501c3s they're
501c4s and they do political advocacy so
maybe their primary goal is not
um
to uh I'm trying to think of an example
maybe their primary goal is not to quote
Lobby or you know but they do a portion
of that and so they do political
advocacy
but they're not tent and I agree with
you I think that they're a kind of a
political committee and they wanted
people wanted to be clear that they were
included in political committees and
they should they set a different
threshold
I you know we passed a bill that
decreased the threshold and put in some
new Provisions this past year but
if we're going to just talk about one
definition when we go through these
definitions with the deputy secretary
then let's I agree I think we need to
look at all of these and that's and
that's why I said when we changed some
of the definitions that's one reason I
wanted to put the thing in word form so
we could go through and find every time
that it's mentioned so that we can catch
it and figure out what else needed to be
changed
not because it's a you know because it's
in that group of things that we've
agreed on does that make sense
I think so
yes yeah it doesn't make sense I agree
with you we need to look at that too
getting back to my was originally saying
about Roman numeral five currently
candidate committee non-candidate
political committee or political
advocacy organization
uh we've talked previously about the
distinction between someone who
files as a candidate
versus someone who files as you know
with a candidate committee
and I I do think that's a meaningful
distinction because a candidate
committee at the
as I understand the current definition
it requires somebody find somebody else
to serve as their Fiscal Agent
what's the difference without a
distinction and they have different
reporting things too
right and on that General topic I think
it would make sense to I want to retain
the distinction because I think
you may laugh at this but I know people
who've run for uh State Rep for example
uh
who considered having to find someone
else willing to accept
the task of managing the finances
the campaign
it was not
something that was easy for them to do
everybody's busy
we've all got lots of things to do
uh every member of the public including
those for taking the time to be here
today thank you very much
but
that's why that's what's behind my
belief we should retain the distinction
it's a low barrier to participation you
just show up your file as yourself right
you declare yourself your own Fiscal
Agent and you're off and running you
don't have to go round up somebody else
even though you may have many supporters
it's a different
uh
just that's one reason I prefer to keep
the distinction
but and this art this Roman numeral five
by any candidate committee Etc
we could reduce the Practical
differences between the two right by
adding the you know candidate in that
list
there's uh the amount to contribute the
the max amount you can contribute to a
candidate or candidate committee to a
non-candidate political committee or
political advocacy add the word
candidate at the beginning candidate
comma candidate committee and then we're
treating those two yeah the same I need
to think about
it yeah
proposing that as a slam dunk here
also non-candidate political committee
and again what maybe we could talk about
this again after we go through some of
the changes that the deputy secretary
because I think she made some changes in
those definitions and we can look at
those
yeah we
I just was a thought I had yeah no I
agree or maybe we could
have to re
need to re-read again
how a candidate committee is defined
right
do we need
and do we need do we need a candidate
committee
in there maybe we
I think we do because for the larger
races that's true okay no yep I I'm not
trying to cut you off but uh yeah yeah I
think for the larger races we need to
have it but again for that Moana the
house raises
I mean I I don't do a candidate
committee so yeah I don't either but I
think a lot of them don't but I think
we can clarify that and make the
reporting requirements the same so in
essence there's not that much difference
I I think we could make the uh reporting
requirements the same I think that's an
obvious thing to change we could all
agree on in terms of the dates
on which the reports have to be filed
and and so on
uh maybe it'd be a simple
in whatever this definition we have of
candidate committee that it allows the
candidate to be
his or her own Fiscal Agent
maybe it would be that simple
right
anyway okay
so what else do you have in your mind to
discuss that was it okay I'm good for
the for the benefit of this public
portion
uh you know for actual public meeting
I'm gonna
uh reiterate what I was saying about a
basic plan for how to proceed from here
which is that
uh
we will plan on wrapping up the
activities of this subcommittee in late
August
with a meeting in which a draft or
drafts of a report of the subcommittee
are presented to the full subcommittee
for them to uh to discuss with them and
to liberate over
and either approve or suggest
amendments we can all agree on
and that will conclude the work of the
subcommittee to
uh
remove the possibility that people could
confuse our legislative duties in
preparing legislative service requests
and so on with the activities of the
subcommittee because we would then again
be free to collaborate on whatever level
right as legislators because we're no
longer members of a public this specific
public body
and that makes sense to both of you
right yes and I will and since this is a
purely administrative matter I will
confer with our
our other two members or other three
members who get their concurrence with
that schedule okay
all righty uh I note that we have a
representative of the Secretary of
State's office here Deputy Hennessey
and if you'd like to give us a quick a
quick overview of your rough draft
it would be very much appreciated
and if you would just state your name
for the
record thank you Mr chair committee
Aaron Hennessey deputy secretary of
state and
um what I have given out is a very rough
draft it's about 20
six pages long it includes all of the
current version of 664. and the way you
can read it is that
um anything in red bold is what I've
added to the language of 664. I've done
strikethroughs which would be
recommended deletions of the statute
anything in highlights or in blue text
it still needs to be addressed
um
and or there's open questions for
someone else to answer
and what I've tried to do is to make it
as simple as possible I haven't tried to
include anything which I think may be
considered
um political in any way just to try and
simplify anything make it much easier
hopefully to understand
I've tried to clear up registering
versus reporting
I've tried to Define what a political
committee is and condense down the
language
I've tried to Define what an election
cycle is versus what it was put in there
in the current version and then for the
election cycle I've TR I've because I
heard a lot of discussion and agreement
from your committee deleted out the
different
um campaign contribution limits for the
three different current cycles of the
election cycle and just make it one
cycle and one limit
um I've gotten rid of the word Fiscal
Agent or agent and just used the word
Treasurer just because they all do the
same thing
I've tried to
um
be as inclusive as I could of things
that I've heard from your conversations
from the ages conversations from
questions that I've gotten
um but it's it doesn't have everything
possible I don't think and every time I
read through it I think of something
else to change or recognize something so
this is the first draft first attempt
I'm happy to go through it very quickly
just to highlight some of the the major
recommended changes if if you would like
me to do that Mr chair well I'd be would
be happy to hear that okay great thank
you let me put my reading glasses on
okay so first off I've included the
language from any bills from 2023 that
have passed that includes HB 195 and the
hb2 language
in the definition section uh because
this had a lot of discussion around it
under 664 to colon 3
um
I've put the definition of a political
committee and included all of the other
committee types that we've previously
discussed in the current
6664 candidate committee is not defined
so now we have it is that instead of
breaking out different types of
political committees and definitions it
says types of political committees
include candidate Committee created by a
candidate running for office non-candid
committee and so on so it's it's more
whenever the word political committee is
used in in the statute you can refer
back and see that's what that means
except if it after the words political
committee it says excluding this type of
political committee
um
you'll see on on page three there's some
highlights
um and this is
this is very um
it's what you would have found if you
read 664 through is that sometimes
there's a lot of internal
inconsistencies for example post office
address
shall not mean an individual's business
address but then when you go down to
principal pace place of business it asks
you to to include the post office
address so there's there's some things
that need to be cleared up
um also occupation means an individual's
official job title but then when you
have to report receipts you have to put
somebody's occupation and their job
title so some some things still need to
be cleared up and that I would leave it
to the legislature to decide what it is
that's important that you information
that you need
um and and what what are you looking for
for a post office address are you
looking for a physical address
um so there's there's some additions
that can be done
um
I defined election cycle and This this
term is going to be used when you're
when we're looking at how much money
someone can collect and in what time
period and there was a lot of discussion
previously that your committee had about
how long can somebody go on with a
deficit in their um in their reporting
how long can somebody maintain a surplus
so the way I've defined it is that an
election cycle means the period of time
beginning on the eighth day after a
state general election through seven
days after the next general election
so any expenditures or receipts that you
have in that time would be
in that election cycle and then the
reporting for that election cycle
I don't know if you recall in the
current version of 664 it has very
complicated reporting paragraphs so on
page 12 I've
um I've tried to take it down to bullet
points of when each report is due and
currently reports are different for
candidates versus political committees
on when the reports are due but I've
just said that
everyone has to report according to the
schedule and it's more of a bullet point
schedule so
um it def the the reporting for each
election cycle will be in that case
reporting versus registering I've heard
from yours
discussions that you possibly think a
candidate should have to register you
think that everyone should use the
online campaign Finance system and the
the way we do it in currently is that
you can register on a paper form or you
can register in the campaign Finance
system if you're going to use the
campaign Finance system as a candidate
you have to register so if you're
pushing everyone towards using the
campaign Finance system everyone has to
register anyway so
um
and the
oh also there's a definition for special
election because that was there was
never a definition anymore so in as you
read through you'll see that I've put in
here that if you have a surplus or a
deficit after if you basically if you
don't have a zero balance after the
election cycle and you've made your
final report according to the new
schedule
um then you're you're done you don't
have to re-register you don't have to do
any more reports but if you have funds
or deficit you're automatically
registered for the next election cycle
so you don't have to remember that oh I
actually have to register again and then
you have to report that balance whatever
it was on the top of your next
ideally in the system it'll be reported
as your opening balance and then and
that's important because I if I remember
correctly
elsewhere in here
it the registration expires some number
of you know a few days after the general
election right right which is
um something extremely confusing we I
find for people who I agree with that
yeah
some of us find that yeah you can't you
can't continue to operate on your
current campaign but
um let's see
okay so it automatically
re-registered someone yes if the deficit
or Surplus yeah for the next election
cycle The Only Exception would be for a
special election because a special
election is just for that special
election and you're not you're not a
candidate that's running for a seat over
and over again so if you if you've
set up if you've registered for a
special election and you wanted to use
it again
you would have to assume that there'd be
another special election that you're
running for but
um so I've tried to Define that out so
if you have a special election
campaign and expenditures and you have a
balance at the end of it you would have
to do what you do now with the balance
and that would be to donate it to your
next campaign so whatever that if you're
going to run for whatever your office
you'd be running for in the next cycle
does that make sense
I think so okay it's what you have to do
now but we just have to make it clearer
in legislation I'll have to actually
take the time to read it
to be sure but
um on pages seven
through nine
I've
um crossed out a lot of the
the language
to meet with what hb2 said but then also
crossed out the
um
the the phases of the campaign cycle
because I haven't included them in the
language so there's no limits for pre
pre-camp pre-filing there's no limits
for the
um general election or the primary it's
just this is the limit for the election
cycle
and that's I haven't changed those
limits that's what hp2 had
or current law
um
so a lot of the big changes that I've
made are in 664 6 reporting by political
committees
um and that includes the I've deleted
several sections and I and I've
Consolidated them into more of a bullet
format
you'll see some highlights there there
was a lot of talk about alphabetical
order if it's done
ultimately if it's done in the system
it'll be in alphabetical order I
highlighted occupation and job title
because
in the definition section they are the
same thing so however you decide to go
forward with with that definition
um
I've tried to put all of the when you
have to register to a certain dollar
amount and I think I've included as a
thousand dollars since that what you've
most recently changed the advocacy
organizations to a thousand dollars
um I've added more information to
um
um the section 5 of 664.
6 about
um
how it will be Autumn conditionally
renewed if you're not a candidate
committee if you've paid your fifty
dollars so this is
the automatic re-registration piece but
in in law there's certain political
committees that have to pay fifty
dollars to register so
um
there's a little
like a
the logic in when if you run for speaker
of the house when you have to report
um you can't
become speaker until your final report
is reported but that deadline for the
final final report is after you're done
with your your race and because you take
the speakership as soon as you're voted
in it's there's a there's some spirals
in there that don't make sense the logic
so that needs to be fixed somehow
however you decide you want to require
that to be done which section is that
um that is in 664 7B Roman numeral three
page 15 yes and I've just highlighted in
blue okay the question there thank you
I've deleted section 664 9A
for
um
readability
let's see
and and uh excuse me you're you're doing
that because
the use of the fax machine is pretty
much
a thing of the past well we get a lot of
calls to the office that they can't read
somebody's statement
and when you fax something you have to
print it out on your home printer
and then fax it and then we get the
facts and then we have to scan it and
upload it in online to the campaign
Finance so there's a lot of places where
it gets degraded over time the
information so I've just deleted that
because we get too many complaints about
it you can put it back in if you like
but also I know that this committee has
talked a lot about about mandating of
when somebody has to use the campaign
Finance system
and because I didn't hear a final I've
just put in an option which is that um
you can um and it's on the top of page
16 that statements of receipts and
expenditures
as required under this section may also
be filed by means of electronic mail put
our email address in there through the
end of the 2024 election cycle
statements filed via the campaign
Finance system shall be publicly
available on the Secretary of State's
website statements filed the electronic
mail sell Republic of the available on
the same website within seven days after
the statement is filed we have a lot of
people who file the statement at the
like five o'clock on the due date and
um
in our office we have limited people who
are able to get the information up and
upload it especially if somebody hasn't
actually registered in the system yet so
we need some time to upload the
information if they've done it
electronic uh via email or fax currently
so
play with that however you feel fit as
as always but I just put them in there
as one of the options
um I haven't had a chance to talk with
anyone a legal expert on what 60 6410 is
trying to accomplish
um so I just put a question in there of
what it means it sounds to me that if
you do one of these activities you don't
have to report it
but if you're using campaign funds I
would assume that you always have to
report all your expenditures otherwise
how can you get to a zero balance
but
I just I just have that question in
there for
um
someone with more legal background for
me than me too answer
um
a lot of changing a Fiscal Agent to
Treasurer in the next sections
foreign I did a little bit of that and I
was doing something similar
and I picked a Fiscal Agent but I
Treasurer Fiscal Agent as long as we use
the same phrase I only found one or two
places where the term Financial agent
was used at all and one thing that I did
not include are two things I didn't
include in here I have a few more things
to discuss but is that
um we at the Secretary of State's office
are happy to assist people set up a
terminal or an iPad or something if
somebody needs assistance with filing
campaign Finance reports online or
registering online we're also happy to
reach out to the libraries across the
state to give them information if
somebody comes in there to use one of
their computers and their internet on
how to use the campaign Finance system
the other thing is is that if I know
that when I ran for the house I had on
my science Fiscal Agent and then my
fiscal agent's name so there may we may
need to put a new section in here that
um
treasure shall also mean Fiscal Agent or
for for those for those house members
who have signs and don't want to have to
reprint signs or something like that who
you know if you already have the
materials that say Fiscal Agent on it
[Laughter]
um that would just be a recommendation
um page 18 uh we have we get a lot of
calls about what you need to say
um your disclosure on who paid for
something
um and it's the language in current law
is a bit confusing
um a lot some people know that they can
put a website but if you go to that
website sometimes there's no information
on there in there of who paid for it who
the fist or Treasurer is so I've tried
to make it much more clear that the
signature shell State paid for by and
you have put the name of the candidate
or candidate committee the address of
the candidate or Canada committee the
name of the treasurer and that um in
lieu of that information you could also
have an internet address and when you
type in that address the website has to
have all of that information
right there available
excuse me what section is that again oh
that's on page 18. 64 14. thank you
mm-hmm
okay thank you
um
I there's a one thought I had on 66414
pre-reported political messages
it it says message uh messages audio
messages is delivered by a telephone
um I I put into a telephone because
sometimes telephones are not used to
deliver the messages
um
the section there's a lot of sections
towards the end of 664 that I would want
to get more input from the AGS office on
I know that they spoke to
spoke to some of that but I would want
to get their their input on that
um and that's
a general overview of the changes and
I'm happy to take any questions
um
and then send this to you when I do have
more feedback from my office and the
AG's office on it
thank you I do have one question uh no
pressure
do you just do you have a feel for when
you think you might have
a more final draft of this just looking
for an idea when would you like a more
final draft yeah that's that's the
question that's the way I used to answer
questions like that when I had a
supervisor
I'm really I'm really looking for a
rough idea and okay I personally will
not hold you to it yeah
um
so you said your meeting in August
so I would say by the end of July would
be very would be you
time frame that would be
it's it's a lot of information it was
not an easy task to go through this I am
not going to come back at you saying
it's late
it's when you have the opportunity to do
it I was just looking for a rough idea
so I could do at least a minimal
planning as to when to apply my efforts
yeah because I think this is this is
going to be very useful to all of us
would you guys agree
that's fantastic I mean esteemed fellow
Representatives
good I'm glad um okay just as somebody
who
had to start using this more on a more
daily basis I can understand a lot of
frustrations where
and the why the why we get phone calls
to the office
thank you very much for that extremely
rough estimate as to the next graph
which we will have forgotten by the time
anyway okay thank you very much and I
also just want to remind you about
August 2nd
um when we will have the new ballot
counting electronic ballot counting
devices for you to cast ballots through
and give your feedback to the ballot law
commission and that will be in this
building I don't know the exact time yet
but more information to come soon
okay oh
yes representative Lane but if she
looked like she's getting ready to leave
some
um when do
types of political committees
um I haven't had a chance to look at
them all are these all kind of defined
in here like a candidate Committee
created
so is candidate committee defined
somewhere else
um
I just haven't had a chance to look at
it
um
I'll have to get I will have to figure
that out okay I can't remember right now
yeah again I just kind of noticed that
and then
uh political advocacy organization
um we had talked about not about maybe
that wasn't necessary did you include
that because when you did more research
you thought it was necessary I just want
to kind of get a sense so that is
defined in here right um so I I kept it
in there because it was it is something
different than some of the other ones
um
okay I think right now in law
um our general counsel's read of it
would be that there's nine different
options right
I don't know that there needs to be nine
different options because one option is
also
one option is a subset of another option
exactly it's yeah I tried to condense
them down okay
I will
in the next version I will make sure
that all of these are defined somehow
okay yeah and I'm probably going to be
tinkering with it too but I you know
well
um
and
we we haven't really talked about
um independent expenditures I mean we
kind of touched on it a couple times and
that that's what the super Pacs were
doing and they kind of
um and
I I was going to try and figure out if
we needed a better definition of
independent expenditure and I I saw that
you didn't do that but we haven't really
talked about it that much on the
committee so I just wondered if that was
one of the reasons I I didn't try unless
there was some inconsistencies another
place I didn't try and fix anything that
would be more of a policy decision
and election cycle I was just curious on
the dates picked and I'm still trying to
wrap my mind around yep you know all
that so so and again this is just my
take on what everyone was saying is that
at some point at some point there needs
to be a cut off between one one election
cycle ends and when the next begins when
somebody should be registering
um if you can
um if you can carry Surplus over or a
deficit over or how long and it's if
there's so many different options for
somebody just to keep going and and
they're not quite sure which of the
filings they should be doing the six
month filings or the new committee
filings if they
um I just tried to make it as simple as
possible and that
the election cycle is a two-year cycle
it starts on the eighth day after the
last general election and ends on the
seventh day following the current
general election
so to get to representative
his concern he
want a candidate
candid fundraising right after you kind
of get around that so it by cutting that
which is why I think he was favoring
like the election day like if you start
doing anything so this would be
this would allow within those eight days
than for somebody to go in and try and
campaign get money for their next
election I know I mean I certainly won't
be doing it but I know that there are
you know people that do it so and have
that capacity to do it so that that
would allow them still to do that just
he's not here so I'm raising this I
think when when I seven days is a very
short window of time to do any
campaigning after an election and what I
I picked seven days because
um currently there's there's a
there's reporting that you have to do
two Wednesdays after the so I I kind of
tried to do it within the same window of
time that you currently have to report
and also if if you are campaigning and
you're super busy up into the election
I'm sure there's some
some expenses and some funds you've
received running up to the election that
haven't been recorded yet correct and so
it just gives a week for somebody to
clean up their books and report
everything okay
that's that was my I was just trying the
purpose of putting that in there so when
he asked the question I know the answer
yeah and
and it's just a suggestion oh sorry did
you turn me off
oh is that what I did oh
[Laughter]
yes I pressed the button on the left by
mistake
Kate so
no
uh so you so you picked through this
seventh day essentially after the
general election because it corresponds
to the day you have to file the report
roughly to when you currently have to
file so it's it's just a date day and
time and all of the
the filings are listed
and now bullet point but
um just based on your committee's
discussion about it's difficult to
figure out when one cycle ends and one
one begins deficits and surpluses I just
picked a a date and time that seemed
reasonable I understand and that was a
very reasonable thing to do for this
rough draft thank you
and I'm doing this again from memory the
AG
suggested they wanted the ability to do
some fines and do anything was that that
I don't see anything in here did I okay
I didn't I didn't I just going off of
their sheet I have I didn't I didn't
want to make the proposed edits without
their input because they they did have
some enforcement requests but I didn't
know what what those specifically should
look like so I figured since they're
lawyers they'd be better at writing the
law than I would be okay I just wanted
to be sure okay thanks
any other comments or questions for the
deputy secretary
I did want to respond to your question
about corporations versus business
organizations and this is my
understanding you would you would want
to reach out to the AG's office but I
believe that any business organization
would be Corporation and that's that's
how the limits would be currently
um maybe a suggestion would be to
replace Corporation in that section with
business organizations since it's
already defined that's what I was
wanting but that would be
I'll follow up with Matthew okay and ask
at the AG's office
okay oh thank you very much for your
time and effort
anything else on my fellow committee
members Minds
okay
we're not required to stay here till
noon
I mean I've said what I was interested
in saying
maybe we've got a good plan we're ready
to go you know I do have one question
for my
bill of Representatives if if either of
you seen an example of a report that
comes out of a subcommittee like this
maybe I could direct that question to
the deputy secretary
thanks
but where's your office
I don't know I just email her okay
and she's usually listening to us
because you remember that time we talked
I do remember that was a very that was a
very helpful could you please come down
Russia if you're listening I'll I'll
find out okay
I'll ask okay
all right so uh if there we have nothing
else to discuss at this time then I will
adjourn the meeting
as of 11 20.
A.M
so the meeting is now adjourned
thank you for being here
fellow members thank you for thank you
deputy secretary and members of the
public
thank you for your interest
this meeting is adjourned